all right faith
yes faith where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i grew up in san
bernardino
san bernardino
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your parents
no i just had my mom i didn't know my
dad
how was your childhood with mom
my mother she usually like
she put men before me
and whatever a man said
or
whatever he wanted to do she let him do
it
your mom was into drugs i assume
yes
that's probably how she'd pay for drugs
yeah she would that was going on for you
at what age
i was around 11.
did it continue or
it continued
until
i was able to leave
until when until i was able to leave
well which his assistant took me out
when did you leave home
i i was able to leave
well i left my i got taken away from my
mother when i was around
14. but i was never at home really
yeah where'd you go at 14
at 14 i went to a placement
for about like two years
and that's when my auntie had took me in
and
the same cycle has started because
my i had a baby by my
my baby father was my pam
and when i was 13 going on 14 i got
pregnant
and i had a baby at 14. so you started
working as a prostitute very early yes
what age did you start
i started around about like
11 it got serious around about
12 and a half
and how did that
happen a lot of grown men
my mother like introduced me to a lot of
grown men so you were already
doing it since you were a young child
yes
and then you you were doing it on your
own at 11 or 12.
i i started around like doing it on my
own like 12.
and the guys would know that you're
underage obviously
they act like they wouldn't know but i
know that they do know because i look
the young yeah
did you finish school
no how far did you go
um i went to about
11th grade
and i stopped
yeah how old are you now
i'm going to be 20 in may
and you're currently working still
you're you were figaro or western or
yes
which one or both i'll work both yeah
and you're doing this on your own or
with a pim no i have a pimp maybe
how is that relationship he beats me
he makes me go out there
and do whatever he
whatever he tells me to do doesn't
matter
and if i don't if he doesn't get his way
he beats me even harder
ends up with bruises scars
feels like i'm going to die sometimes
but
i am surviving
do you feel like you can get away
it's very hard
he's a crazy man yeah
he's life-threatening
he's
i'm sure he's part of a gang
yes yeah so it's not as easy as just
going to the cops
it becomes very difficult
he's a very dangerous man yeah
only willing to do whatever just to make
them happy whatever satisfies them if
they don't feel like they're satisfied
they're going to do whatever they do
to get whatever when you have other
wifeys other girls that are under him
i haven't really met him
he like keeps me like captive like you
know in a box
so
i
i met one of them before but that was me
beating he forced me to beat her up
and that he was beating her up at the
same time
it was like a very bloody scene
i didn't understand why
i was hurt i didn't want to do it but i
was forced to
i'm sure you have a quota every night
yes
how much do you have to make every now
at least a thousand men
and typically what hours will you work
i'm basically
all hours of the day like i
barely get breaks you work every day
yes
when's the last time you hit a day off
it's been a while
i say like
when i was in the hospital
where were you i'm afraid to ask where
were you in the hospital for i had a
baby oh you had a baby
how many children do you have now i have
three
and who are you raising them
no who where are the children
they brought my family
my aunt
and your family knows that you're doing
this
yeah
they
they know they don't wanna they don't
want any parts because they don't want
like any trouble or any harm towards
them yeah because it's dangerous to the
family yeah so i keep it away from them
and why are the police not the answer to
the situation that you're in
i don't know like i tried to you know
get help and all that but
they just
they saying i have to do like strange
orders and
everything that's not like
what's supposed to happen right then and
there yeah the gangs operate on a very
different
set of rules than than the police or
anyone else really
especially in south central and it's not
like i'm ever like
when they saying that they have to be
there when it's happening but what's
happening i don't have a phone like you
know
or he won't let me get in contact with
anything
so it's it's not it's not easy to catch
it right when i'm getting beaten right
it just sounded crazy when i said it
your situation is a common one right
it's not like you're one of one of a
millionaire there's probably a lot of
girls that are in a very similar
situation to yours
yeah i just haven't like really met a
lot no but i have
i think there's a lot of this going on
yeah down there
and how does this how's it doing this
this lifestyle that you have now how
does this affect you
you've been doing it since you're a
young girl
it hurts me i try to i know i know one
day i find a way out
i just pray to god that i just
that's something just a blessing comes
along
and saves me
[Music]
did you have dreams of doing something
with your life other than
working the streets
i do
i i used to want to become a lawyer or a
nurse
like something to involve helping people
because
i know i want to be helped
and i have more sympathy towards people
in need
children older i don't like abuse at all
like
if i if i'm able to help i would love to
be
to serve my life as helping children and
you know abuse
people
like me yeah
that's great
dear friends
i
i wouldn't call them friends
a lot of people that i can trust i
always like let me wrong
so
i never try to like
have anybody close to me
i just can't trust anybody
i have trust issues
i'm sure
you know drugs are part of your life
not commonly
i'm sorry not commonly but
sometimes but not all the time
is that crystal meth
sometimes
you get to see your children
not really not often
on the phone
face time
but i really don't get to see him
i miss him a lot though
is this a lonely lifestyle for you
seems like it
but i know god has a plan
that
i'll be able to get him back
and
we can all be a family i just wouldn't
want a man to be a part of it because i
just can't trust men
especially as much as the pieces i have
went through with them
i don't know if it's like really such
thing as love out there
i don't believe love is true
how cause how could you say that you
love somebody but you hurt them so bad
how could you hurt something that you
love so much
did you ever see anybody any examples of
a loving relationship when you were
young
no
i
i haven't seen any relationships but i
would be
i came from abusive nature
a very abusive nature
my family was always violent
they didn't show that they love each
other as much
as they say they do
love something that i'm still
questioning myself
what it is
and how's your relationship with your
mom now
my mother is the same person i don't
think she's ever going to change
she still has a sick the sick mind that
she has
but she she grew up through
abuse as a child too
so i don't know if she knows how to love
but you seem to be of the mindset that
you could break the cycle
yes seems like i
i'm praying to god that i'll find a way
to
you sometimes feel that life is unfair
yes
a lot
i question why i have to go through this
why has to be me why do i have to suffer
so much
and when will the suffering ever be over
i just lived a life with a lot of pain
i never felt the love and the care that
i need
never had the attention that i needed
you feel betrayed by your may your mom
and maybe your dad too
i do
i wish that my dad was in my life to
show me what a man is supposed to be
and i wish my mother was a mother to
protect me
instead of
giving me up so easily
do you still have hope
i have a lot of hope you see him too
i'm not gonna give up
until i see that the real truth if
it is
a way out
i know there's a way out though
it's just not as easy as
it's not as easy as it looks no i mean
for viewers that don't quite understand
what's going on
the gangs in south central are
incredibly powerful
and very dangerous
and you can't just like go to the police
you can't just
leave you can't just walk away and i
can't step in and protect you and
without some kind of repercussions
yes either way they don't try to find me
or your family
and hurt me or whoever's close to me
and that's the problem
because if you
didn't have that
in play then you could just walk away
and go somewhere else and go live
somewhere else or do whatever you like
but
is it almost like you're a prisoner
it feels like that
it feels like
walls are caving in
and i'm not free
i have i feel like i have no freedom
i don't have no say-so of anything in my
life
like i'm gonna be in control like a
puppet
it's gotta be depressing
it is
what are you afraid of
i'm afraid of losing my life
when my life is
having me started
yeah
tell me about the guys who are your
customers you guys who pick you up
they're just
guys that want one thing one thing only
they don't care if they're rough
as long as they're satisfied that's all
that matters to them
they don't have no respect for us
they don't look at us with no respect
it's like
it's like we're not even human to them
did you have any good positive role
models in your life when you're a young
girl
your mom was certainly not one brother
my grandmother
my grandmother had a big heart
and she tried her best to
to keep our family together
but it kept making her sick because she
stressed so much and there's so much she
could do
but she was a strong woman
how are you introduced to crystal matt
it was a
it was from a white guy that was
supposed to be saving me from a mother's
boyfriend
my mother boyfriend had a gun out a gun
to my forehead
and
was gonna kill me and that's when this
one
is one white thing came out and
he had saved me he had a rifle on him
and that's when my mother's boyfriend
had jumped the fence and just got on
and i had stays with that white dude
but i didn't know like
what he did or anything until he had
went to go pick up something he took us
back to took me back to the room
and the first drug i ever tried was here
on
i didn't like it
i had smoked it and it made me feel
it made me feel too good it was still
good to be true
i never wanted to try it again
and then he introduced me to crystal
meth
ever since then i've been hooked on it
ever since
i liked it too much
it helps you stay up all night and work
it helps me stay focused while i'm
working and helped you stay up
have you had bad things happen to you
and you've been working on the streets
yes what kind of stuff have you i have
been raped
i've been tortured
i have been brought to places that i
don't even know where i'm at
like i have
somebody took me to the mountains
um
i've been to far
far places like way out that i i didn't
know
where i was at at all like i have
never been to
and
i didn't know how to get back sometimes
but
obviously i got back
it was a lot of sick stuff that happened
to me
a lot of
pain
and confusion
that hurt me
what have you learned about men from
doing this kind of work and going
through those kind of experiences
it's a lot of sick ass men out there
and you cannot trust all men
all man is not to be trusted
no matter how they come at you
you never know who they are
until they try to they show their true
colors
you can be with a man for
a lot of years and you still want to
know who they are
you have to be careful
very careful but man
they'll put you in situations that you
never think that you'd be in
and do you get ask to do things like
that have sex without a condom and
things like that
yes and a lot of women forcibly try to
trick you
a lot of
sickness like
it doesn't matter to them as long as
they're satisfied that's all that cares
do you ever end up doing things that
you wish you hadn't in terms of
yeah risky forced to
a lot of force
i like most of the time
they don't try to give us a choice
and i don't have the strength of a man
so it's like i can't overpower them
someone said i have to deal with it
have you ever been out of south central
have you ever traveled anywhere
never lebanese vegas i haven't even been
out there like
what'd you go to vegas for
to work
your pimp would take you there
yes
have you had more than one pan for just
just him i had more than one pin how
many pimps have you had
i've been tossed around like a big bag
i can't even like really count
how do you typically go from one pim or
how do you leave a pimp
how have you left some of your pimps
it's either they leave me
or didn't toss me on to the next person
or something happens to them they go to
jail
it just happens that way it just tossed
me around like a big bag
from one pin to another
you think if you grew up in another
part of the country
a better neighborhood perhaps that this
may not have happened
yeah
i would have more like
my my parents
would be more sophisticated
in the mind than what they are now
they wouldn't be so close and so blind
to what they're doing to their self
that's hurting us yeah
what is your mom's drug is it crack or
crystalline
my mother she she was an alcoholic
she she did a lot of pills she did
crystal
that's why i knew
probably more
if you could have changed one thing
about your
childhood
what would you have changed
i can't say i could change my mother
i'll probably change the way
i'll probably change the way i dressed
change what like the way i was i
wouldn't be so girly girl yeah i
probably like would have been boys so i
wouldn't have attention for men
is there a culture in south central that
these girls that walk the street and
dress so
dress as a lot of girls on figaro or
western will
is is like it's glamorous in it it's
more of a sex symbol
yeah it's almost like a modeling
like a fashion show yeah it's like a
yeah it's like a runway
so a young girl drives by and sees that
and becomes like something
you aspire to
no
yeah and it's sad because they don't
know what all comes
like comes with it until they actually
do it they don't understand how hard it
is to get away from me
it's a deep gang
and it's hard to stop it
it's hard to stop playing yeah
especially if that's all you know
are you saving any money
doing this
you're giving it all the way to your
pimp i assume
yeah he knows where i could hide the
money
so you're not able to keep any of it
only if i send it away
sometimes i
i'll send some western union to my
mother
so she can send it to my aunt
or
something but i try not to do it that
way so many times because i don't even
trust my mother
but what do you think most people don't
understand about girls that do this kind
of work
didn't understand the pain that we go
through
and the abuse that we feel
and the loneliness
it's a very harsh game
and most of the time it ain't our fault
i think if you're
if you're
the men to pick you up understood how
much
trauma and pain is behind
they probably have more symptoms they
probably wouldn't treat you the way they
do
right
most of these men are sick
i'm sorry there's a lot of sick men out
there on if the world wasn't like that
what it is
i feel sorry for the generations that's
growing up all the little girls to have
to suffer through it
because i know exactly how that pain
feels
honey if there's a way to say save all
the little girls that's going through
the abuse that we go through but it's
not
if only if the system took it as
as serious as it needs to be taken
then it
it'll be more
it will be less girls going through it
but the system may overlook it
what do you think the answer to the
whole
situation is is is the problem poverty
is the problem that these families
are desperate to survive somehow
yes i think comes from a lot of stress
and
a lot of
a lot of worriedness
that has a person going through
trusting somebody
and
doing things that they have to do to
survive
the combination of poverty and broken
families and lack of education and lack
of opportunities yes just creates a
snake pit
yes
where everyone's a hustler and
everyone's counting everyone
yes it's like wherever
the place that you come from is where
a person is going to look at you as
they look down on the ones that come
from the ghetto
because they don't know how to get aways
and
they don't understand how
like we how the way we act how we talk
they don't understand why we talk that
way but it's like because we don't know
no better
if we would have had more
knowledge
and more like attention
to be like taught another way
it'll be different
but they don't focus on us as much
and then you throw racism on on top of
everything else and it
becomes a very stubborn problem yes
it was a lot of hatred
and it shouldn't even be that way
because i think they were all human
no matter what skin color we are we came
from the same place
we talk the same walk the same we have
the same body parts it's just the color
of our skin that changes us
you seem very evolved for a girl that
comes from the family and the
environment you're
in why do you think you're
thinking the way you are
and saying the things you are my family
are mixed
my sister she's she's half white
my grandmother she's half white
my dad he's simone
so it's like
we have like mixtures in our bags of all
kinds yeah and half of my family like
they look down on the dark-skinned ones
because they're lighter than
lighter than us
i'm like one of the darker skins is
there is there like a hierarchy of
skin color in the
black community
yeah
it's a lot of like racism like the
darker you are the darker you are the
worser you are
that's what they look
the darker the less what less desirable
basically they don't we don't
the darker we are we're not as much
want it
as the lighter skins
i don't understand why
but they say that we're more uglier
and
stupider and all that stuff like it's
just
it looked down on the darker skins
it's like racism
even in the black community
yes it is
[Music]
they look more of the beauty
instead of like
what it should be
basically the person that we are
faith what do you say is the most
important
thing you've learned in your 20 years
the most important thing that i've
learned
is to survive
how to stay alive
that's the most important you're a
survivor that's for sure
all right faith thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck out there
thank you so much for having me here
thank you
you